où
nous
nous sommes à mâcon au sud de la
saône-et-loire le mardi 1er juin 1999 où
ce soir là vanessa thialon jeune
apprentie cuisinière de 17
de passer la soirée avec son petit ami
les heures passent
et elle commence à s'impatienter
des faux nez c'était minuit pour dire
qu'il arrivait donc et sont disputés au
téléphone je vais du mahdi j'y vais je
dit non tu descends pas c'est pas la
peinture
tu verras viennent aux mains non non
elle a dit j'y vais à la peau et son
gilet à les descentes sont disputés sur
le parquet je suis interne et de là avec
sa soeur de se coucher
c'est le lendemain matin ce qui n'était
pas leur je me suis pas inquiétée parce
qu'elle a et en sentant dormir chez sa
copine qui habite pas noir donc je dis
allez chez core i
vanessa jeune fille en pleine crise
d'adolescence avait la fâcheuse habitude
de fuguer pendant plusieurs jours mais
cette fois ci n'ayant vraiment aucune
nouvelle sa maman finit par se poser des
questions jusqu'au jour où je dis je
vais aller au commissariat quand même
parce que corinne non plus n'avait pas
de nouvelles
mais cette nuit là le pire est
malheureusement arrivé à la jeune
vanessa t-il
ce a retrouvé quatre jours plus tard le
5 juin 1999
e
dans la saône il y a peu de traces sur
le corps mais en tous les cas et une
autopsie sera effectuée
puisque dans un premier temps elle n'est
pas identifié
les policiers du commissariat de mâcon
donc très peu d'éléments pour identifier
la jeune fille retrouvée complètement
dévêtue sur les berges du centre
nautique
j'avais une chaussure ils m'ont montré
la chaussure jeudi ses seuls c'est
celle-là en plus était neuve je venais
de lui acheter
et là on nous a dit que le corps qu'ils
avaient cessé ce que moi tant que je les
ai pas vus j'ai pas cru
le corps est bien celui de vanessa
tiello une autopsie a été effectuée mais
les conclusions du médecin légiste reste
très flou ce qui est très étonnant on
est quand même en 99
c'est que les causes de la mort de cette
jeune fille qui retrouve est quand même
assez rapidement ne sont pas ne sont pas
résolues ne sont pas identifiés on ne
sait pas de quoi elle est morte
finalement le médecin légiste va dire
qu'il ne sait pas de quoi elle est morte
mais que c'est probablement quand même
d'une overdose
les magistrats et les enquêteurs en
charge de cette affaire ne s'oriente
visiblement pas vers la thèse du meurtre
et une fois la structure m'a dit rien ne
prouve qu'elle s'est pas suicidé
d'ailleurs je lui ai répondu et l'avocat
de mladic de sortir du bureau parce que
l'hypothèse du suicide n'est pas
envisageable pour la famille et de
nombreux éléments recueillis au cours
des investigations ne colle pas avec
cette théorie qu'on la retrouve dévêtu
dans la saône pourquoi on la retrouve
avec des traces de des hémato on nous
indiquera quand même que on n'a pas
trouvé de trace de drogue et que
finalement puisqu'on en a pas trouvé
c'est forcément une drogue qui a disparu
dans les cinq jours de son corps on sait
pas si c'est une consommatrice
habituelle on voit dans le dossier en
tous les cas que ça n'est pas le cas et
puis on peut tuer avec de la drogue et
on se pose pas la question
on l'a trouvé dans la zone passait rien
à voir
le petit copain de vanessa est tout de
même soupçonné pendant un temps mais
rien ne prouve sa culpabilité
après plusieurs semaines d'enquêté le
dossier n'est plus prioritaire pour les
policiers toute façon le le dossier
habib a été laissé de côté et moi je
pensais qu'ils travaillaient et j'ai
plus une avocate qui elle non plus n'a
pas voilà il vettier l'on va alors faire
la connaissance des membres de
l'association christelle des familles de
saône et loire qui se bat depuis des
années pour que les meurtres de leur
fille ne soit pas classée sans suite le
dossier est actif il est repris par un
magistrat il ya des demandes qui ont été
formés donc on attend le résultat de ces
investigations qui ont été sollicités
dans la sphère bletterie les analyses
adn demandé à maintes reprises par les
avocats ont récemment permis
l'arrestation d'un suspect des avancées
qui ne laisse pas yvette tient loin
différentes
ils pressent pas pour les autres
dossiers
il faut continuer oui parce que c'est
il faut continuer